Satoshi Nakamoto invented Bitcoin and
more importantly its underlying
blockchain technology no matter what the
future price of Bitcoin may be the real
treasure is blockchain because it's
going to change the world as much as the
internet did in the 1990s Satoshi
Nakamoto was nominated for the Nobel
Prize in Economics and he is a multi
billionaire and yet no one knows what he
actually looks like he might not even be
a single person and the name may serve
as a cover for a group who came together
for the sake of starting a digital
revolution on today's by graphics we're
gonna go over what we know about this
little known figure as well as the
theories behind his secret identity in
the 1980s and 90s the closest thing you
had to a cool gang of rebellious
computer hackers was the cypher punks
they were computer programmers who were
interested in creating absolute privacy
in the digital world they specialized in
creating ciphers that were nearly
impossible to break into many of them
were anarchists and libertarians who
believes that everyone should be
connected online without government
interference sadly as we now know the
Internet is anything but free from the
watchful eyes of the NSA many of these
cypher punks experimented in the idea
that the internet could be used to send
digital money without the use of a
middleman david trom invented digit cash
in 1989 and he published an academic
paper on the subject
another one of the cypherpunks Nick
Szabo created bitgold all of these they
were close but no cigar
even though the cypherpunks have this
idea conceives they couldn't actually
come up with a technical way to
accomplish a true peer-to-peer
experience you see when you're using the
internet you're depending on your
internet service provider and they need
to abide by the laws of each respective
country with apps like PayPal and venmo
sending money to your friends it
probably seems like an instant
peer-to-peer experience at least for you
as the customer but behind the scenes
these companies still have to settle
bank transactions the old-fashioned way
this is three days worth of paperwork
through an antiquated and expensive
system called Swift
if this sounds ridiculous in this day
and age
that's because it really is the global
digital banking system has been long do
an overhaul further after the 2008 stock
market crashed the world
it was primed and ready for a financial
revolution in October of 2008 someone
going by the name of Satoshi Nakamoto
wrote a paper called Bitcoin a
peer-to-peer electronic cash system he
began to email all the cypherpunks
asking if they were willing to help him
create his idea of a new system that he
called blockchain this was a computer
network that truly was peer-to-peer
there would be no fear that your
internet service provider would shut it
down the blockchain is basically an
accounting system that records all
transactions on a public ledger instead
of the US dollar value would be
exchanged in a digital currency called
Bitcoin new bitcoins have to be created
by mining which is a process of
computers attempting to solve a
difficult maths problem once the cipher
is solved that miner is rewarded with a
Bitcoin in the beginning one Bitcoin was
only worth a fraction of a penny back
then and he run-of-the-mill computer you
just got from your local Best Buy could
handle mining Bitcoin and anyone could
receive and deposit the currency in that
digital wallet the blockchain itself
exists in the cloud which is a sort of
hive minds that does not exist in any
physical location this means that no
government in the world has the ability
to shut it down because as long as there
are miners somewhere out there in the
world who are running the blockchain
Bitcoin will continue to exist even
though it was the solution they had been
searching for many of the cypherpunks
ignored Satoshi nakamoto's ideas the
thing is they weren't kids anymore they
were in their 40s and 50s and that
already tried and failed to make their
own digital currencies the idea of
Bitcoin it was so radical that it seems
like something out of a science-fiction
movie but one give you two programmer
from California named how Finney saw its
potential and he was the first person to
take Satoshi Nakamoto seriously he asked
to work on the Bitcoin project for free
ends on January the 3rd 2009 Bitcoin was
first launched how finian Satoshi
Nakamoto who have never met face to face
and they've never spoken over the phone
Mackey moto
left his email address on the Bitcoin
website allowing anyone to contact him
with any questions that they might have
about the project this led to many other
programmers joining him and
helping them in the very beginning this
idea it was only popular to anarchists
and libertarians who had the goal of
living their lives free from government
or rule while they are small in number
this community is incredibly passionate
about their philosophies to this very
day they were the first ones to cling on
to this Bitcoin revolution and many
called Satoshi Nakamoto hero of course
once the word got out that Bitcoin was a
way to transfer money privately it was
almost immediately adopted by criminals
in 2011 a website called the Silk Road
appeared in a web browser called tor
which is used to browse the dark web the
founder and kingpin of the Silk Road
goes by the name of Dread Pirate Roberts
like the character from The Princess
Bride you can buy anything on the Silk
Road including human slaves and hid
orders from assassins and most of these
transactions they're all done in Bitcoin
in 2013 a 29 year old man named Ross
Ulbricht was arrested under suspicion of
being the Dread Pirate Roberts in 2015
he was convicted of conspiracy to
transfer narcotics and since he was
labeled as an evil king then he was
given not just one but two life
sentences plus an additional 40 years
without the possibility of parole
the average Silk Road drug dealer and he
got five to ten years behind bars most
people in the cryptocurrency community
believed that ohlbrecht was just a patsy
and the real Dread Pirate Roberts has
gone freed the FBI seized Russell bricks
cache of bitcoins and auction them off
to the highest bidder
while all bricked was in solitary
confinement someone else logged into the
Dread Pirate Roberts account on the Silk
Road either he had passed the account to
another kingpin or they truly did arrest
the wrong man
so once Bitcoin started getting a lot of
bad press Satoshi Nakamoto was very
upset to see how his project was being
used for evil the last known person to
have communicated with Satoshi Nakamoto
was Gavin Andresen
a programmer who looked up to Nakamoto
as his mentor and hero when the FBI and
CIA came looking for Satoshi Nakamoto
Gavin Andresen agreed to speak with them
about Bitcoin on the mysterious founders
behalf because he wanted to help educate
them about what a blockchain technology
actually is this must have frightened
Akimoto because he completely cut off
ties with
rest of the original Bitcoin team since
then Satoshi nakamoto's Bitcoin public
wallet addresses remained untouched even
in 2017 when the price ballooned to
$20,000 per coin
he is never withdrawn his money he
should be one of the richest men in the
worlds but he has decided not to spend a
penny of it for people who were paying
attention to Bitcoin since its inception
many founds that they could turn
blockchain technology into an
opportunity to make their own businesses
since the code for blockchain was open
source and free for anyone to use it
could be improved and built upon boy
genius vitalik butcherin was just 17
years old when he began to learn how to
code block shaman's founded Bitcoin
magazine he gains a lot of respect from
people who were much older than he was
and he proposed a new project called
etherium this wasn't just another coin
to compete with Bitcoin though it was
far faster and cheaper and people could
build their own businesses upon the
etherion platform these were called IC
O's or initial coin offerings
unfortunately though the vast majority
of these cryptocurrency businesses were
and still are total scams the
government's agencies of the world they
suddenly had a whole lot more to worry
about than just Bitcoin because
uneducated people around the world
started to dump their life savings into
fraudulent companies in the hopes that
it would be the next Bitcoin at the
moment there are very few alternative
coins that are legitimate companies and
not simply scams at the time this video
was made the number two crypto currency
in the world is ripple this is because
they're an actual corporation led by the
former CEO of AOL Brad Garlin house they
have offices in multiple countries where
they have hundreds of employees working
to educate major corporations about what
blockchain can help them do they are
already working hand in hand with the
Federal Reserve and of contracts with
over 200 banks who have agreed to use
their currency X R P R to settle
trillions of dollars in bank
transactions in the future
[Music]
while many of the leaders in traditional
finance and tacker trying to figure out
how to incorporate blockchain in the
real world there are the purists who
still passionately believe in the
anarchist ideals of the cypherpunks
and of Satoshi Nakamoto many of these
original followers were made
multimillionaires by their initial
investments while some of these people
were coders who understood blockchain
technology the majority of them had no
background in computer science at all
them were supporting Bitcoin simply for
the fact that they believed in its
philosophy Satoshi Nakamoto was never
the CEO of Bitcoin because it's not even
a business entity he was never trying to
be a leader but the level of reverence
that some people have for him has been
compared to a cult on multiple occasions
without it leader to guide them Bitcoin
believers debate over the question of
what would Satoshi do they quote an
analyzers old emails and his
publications the reddit boards are
filled with heated debates trying to
interpret Satoshi's words as if they're
their Bible at this point in time
Bitcoin transactions take several hours
or even days to go through and they cost
roughly forty dollars in fees per
transaction it's got to the point where
it's almost as expensive and as slow as
the old school banking system the idea
of saying Bitcoin will be around forever
is kind of like saying that dial-up
internet should still be around too even
though the tech has been in a serious
downward spiral and other companies like
ripple have drastically improved upon
blockchain technology in recent years
much of the Bitcoin community is just in
total denial they continue to have blind
faith in the original Bitcoin and in a
man or group who isn't even around
anymore to give their input the original
programmer of Bitcoin Hal Finney
suffered from ALS also known as Lou
Gehrig's disease if you aren't already
aware this is the same neurodegenerative
disease that immobilized Stephen Hawking
it's where someone's brain is fully
functional but they no longer have
control over their body the timeline of
how Phineas condition getting worse
actually it lines up with Satoshi
Nakamoto deciding to disappear Andy
Greenberg a senior writer at Wired
magazine made the connection and he
believed that he had cracked the case so
he went to interview him at this point
pal Feeny was in a wheelchair and he
could no longer speak he could only
answer yes
or no questions greenberg asked
point-blank if it's true that he was
Satoshi Nakamoto
Phinney's eyes glistened an amusement
and he promptly responded no even though
Hal Finney has become a
multi-millionaire from mining Bitcoin in
the early days of the project no amount
of money could save him from the disease
but maybe he could postpone the
inevitable on the brink of death finning
requested that his body be cryogenically
frozen in the hopes that someday he
would be unfrozen and given cure to ALS
in 2014 he passed away and his body was
transported to a lab in Arizona just two
miles away from health in his home the
FBI showed up on someone's property with
a warrant they dragged out a man with
black hair and glasses and arrested him
under suspicion of being the mysterious
founder of Bitcoin he insisted over and
over that he had no idea what they were
talking about his full legal name that
would be Dorian Satoshi Nakamoto after
the paparazzi showed up at his doorstep
the news falsely reported that Dorian
Satoshi Nakamoto was the true founder of
Bitcoin this sends him into the
spotlight of the media and he had to go
on record with The Associated Press
insisting that he did not have anything
to do with the project and that someone
had clearly taken his name as a
pseudonym today Dorian Nakamoto has been
affectionately titled the fake Satoshi
and members of the community actually
loved him his face was even turned into
a meme many people felt sorry that he
was dragged into this and even donated
bitcoins to him is sort of sorry for the
mix-up in 2017 those donations inflated
to be worth two hundred and seventy
three thousand dollars and he quickly
cashed out at just the right time today
Dorian Nakamoto has actually embraced
the community and he now enjoys being a
celebrity and taking photos with his
fans then in 2015 yet another potential
candidate emerged in the media US
authorities raided the home of an
Australian man named dr. Craig Wright in
2016 right agreed to do multiple press
interviews claiming that he was the real
Satoshi Nakamoto when he gave his
evidence to journalists they were
satisfied not knowing that he had pulled
the equivalent of a technical parlor
trick
some people will believe some people
won't
and to tell you the truth I don't really
care most people don't know how easy it
is to fake this kind of proof on
blockchain so it has been published in
multiple venues that here's the real
Satoshi Nakamoto but after seeing the
likes of the BBC in the Economist
vouching thin many people in the cult of
Satoshi began to believe that their
Messiah had returned and he was back to
tell them exactly what to do with their
money during a public interview boy
genius vitalik Boucheron gave a number
of examples of our Craig Wright could
have faked this so-called proof and he
gave the examples of how he should have
proven that he was the real Satoshi
Nakamoto but it failed to do so
booter and said signalling theory says
that if you have a good way to prove
something and you have a noisy way to do
it then the reason why you picked the
noisy way was because you couldn't do
the good way in the first place Craig
rice is in fact profiting office sudden
claim to fame he is an outspoken showman
appearing before crowds making promises
about bitcoins future in reality he has
started his own company and the promises
he makes are actually not that
impressive where the tech is concerned
he made millions of dollars from
investors simply by claiming that he is
the real Satoshi Nakamoto in many ways
he seems to be like The Wizard of Oz but
many have not been fools in February of
2018 Craig Wright was sued for stealing
10 billion dollars of cryptocurrency
assets from his former business partners
the lawsuit is still ongoing so at the
time we're making this video we can't be
sure of the outcome a journalist named
Andrea Hagen has done a very deep dive
into the Craig Wright case and he has
discovered that rice also lost a lot of
money in the past from a cryptocurrency
firm called Liberty Reserve in Costa
Rica right Olsen met face to face with
Ross Ulbricht soon before his arrest so
why on earth with this millionaire
businessman be associating with a drug
dealer from the Silk Road
some people theorized that Wright isn't
Satoshi Nakamoto at all and he may
actually be the true Dread Pirate
Roberts
[Music]
[Applause]
there are dozens of theories of who is
Satoshi Nakamoto Trulia's from Elon Musk
to the NSA one of masks former interns
at SpaceX Sahil Gupta wrote a
comprehensive blogpost on medium as to
why he believed that his former boss was
the real Satoshi Nakamoto this caused
such a stir that anonymous counter
tweets that he was not the founder of
Bitcoin everyone of course has a very
passionate reason for believing that
their theory is the correct one whoever
he is we may never have seen Satoshi
Nakamoto in the news at all even under
another name it's very possible that he
knew better than to put himself in the
limelight and it would be impossible to
guess his identity if he kept in the
shadows but if Satoshi Nakamoto is still
alive and Ziff he is truly just one man
or even a group of people why haven't
they touched those billions of dollars
that are sitting in their Bitcoin wallet
is there really a person on this planet
with the willpower to resist that kind
of temptation and what does he think
about the corrupt system that Bitcoin
has become in 2012 Satoshi Nakamoto
wrote in an email to one of the original
core developers of bitcoin Mike Hearn
that ripple is interesting in that it's
the only other system that does
something with trust beside concentrated
into a central server what she is
basically saying is that it's the only
other coin he considered a real
contender and admits that it's truly an
improvement on Bitcoin in his last email
the author wrote that had given up on
Bitcoin and wanted to work on another
project without giving any details as to
what that new project actually was and
this leads us to our final theory David
Schwartz who is now the lead
cryptographer ripple in 1988 Schwartz
filed a patent of a distributive
computer network before the existence of
the Internet in lots of ways his idea
was almost identical to Bitcoin 20 years
before Satoshi Nakamoto appeared on the
scene Schwartz is no stranger to using
aliases either and he went by the
pseudonym Joe counts online for many
years there is no denying that he was
intelligent enough to come up with this
on his own Schwartz has used his
knowledge to turn the ripple ecosystem
into a product that is far more
sustainable than Bitcoin ever was it
doesn't need to be mined their
transactions are settled within a few
seconds and each transfer costs a
fraction of a penny
banks around the world already beginning
to use the ripple network because it's
the only one that's even remotely
possible to use in the real world David
Schwartz has an estimated net worth of
ninety million dollars if ripple
succeeds as much as many believe it will
he may become a billionaire at some
point in the future this would serve as
a rational explanation as to why he
hasn't touched the fortune and bitcoin
is because he doesn't want the
possibility that it may lead back to him
and he became so rich with ripple that
he doesn't actually need it
when presented with this theory David
Schwartz denies it of course but that's
probably what the real Satoshi would
totally say so I really hope you found
their video interesting and it was a
little different from on normal videos
here with us not really knowing anything
about the man but there you have it I do
hope you enjoyed it give it a like if
you did leave us a comment let me know
what your thought if you look into
something else to check out why not
check out my other channel called top
tens you'll find a link to that below
this video and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]